- Wrapping up with a long day.
Oh my god!
(yelling and exclaiming)
Holy shit!
Definitely a
different kind of DailyVee.
("Monday to Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Man] Can I help you guys?
- [Gary] It's the way
to collect a lot of data.
- [Woman] Just be careful.
- [Gary] No worries.
- [Woman] It's
not like I expect you
to, like, cut through the walls.
- [Gary] Yeah,
I wasn't gonna. (laughs)
Hey guys, first of
all thank you so much
for listening to my podcast,
it means the world to me.
That little buzzing sound
you hear in the background
is I'm in some sort of
weird utility closet right now
about to go live
stream at Salesforce,
but I wanted to
set up this clip.
This is maybe the
single most important clip
I've ever put out on my podcast.
So, I hope you enjoy it.
Pay very close attention.
And I love you.
(laughs)
Yeah, I love you.
Sure, DRock.
I'm about to do a live stream,
you know, live cast
with Salesforce
for sales executive
and startup and large
companies and I'm excited.
I'm also reading the
Dont'a Hightower resigned
with the Patriots
instead of the Jets
which actually makes me happy.
I didn't want to overpay for him
and I've enjoyed hating him.
It would have been a
tough transition to loving him.
Good morning, good afternoon,
good whatever you call it
wherever you are.
Good to see you.
Big ups Rich.
Snyder Mike, my man,
Snyder Mike,
congrats on Dont'a Hightower
resigning with the Patriots.
Ooh, yeah, that's right.
Macho Man Randy Savage.
Savage, baby. So, I'm
here at Salesforce.
And I am about to do a live...
Why can't I figure
out what it's called?
Live stream? It's a live stream.
Anyway, I'm
looking forward to it.
DRock's here, as always.
What do you guys call this?
Like, what is it
officially called?
A live stream?
- [Man] A web cast?
- A web cast.
I think it is a web cast.
- [Host] So, Gary,
- [Gary] Yes?
- [Host] You have a
really interesting background.
Obviously, moving into
the U.S., the baseball cards,
the Wine Library, perhaps
for some of the people who
are not familiar with yourself,
can get an intro.
- [Gary] You know, it's fun.
Right now I'm very much
known as a marketing guy,
a social media
guy but the truth is,
at the end of the day,
and it's why I really wanted
to do this today is
I'm a sales guy, right?
I mean, from the age
of five with lemonade,
and I mean a five
lemonade stand franchise.
("Understand" by
Bazanji Ft. Eve Devonport)
What is it again?
The Daily Digital Deep Dive.
Anyways, I like the logo.
Put the logo up as it is.
It should live on
GaryVaynerchuk.com
This is amazing.
My man, I have some fun news.
- [DRock] Is there a reason
that the bracket's
so important to you?
- I've just have
always liked it.
In the eight grade I got really
into the NCAA tournament.
Oh, actually, yeah
there is a reason.
My freshman year of
high school I predicted that
the Richmond Spiders
were gonna beat Syracuse
and it was a fifteen
to two seed game
and it was one of the
first time it ever happened
and I went all around
my high school the day of
and I would get into class early
and write "Richmond
Spiders," because we were
a northeast school,
Jersey, Syracuse was big,
it was a monster
upset and, like,
the whole school knew
who I was the next day.
They were like "Some
short freshman predicted it."
And, like, teachers
would pull me outta class
for, like, betting
and it became my signature
moment of my freshman
year and so I think
that's probably what...
Oh, and I also ran the pool in
school junior and senior year
Here's a good racket:
I had a crazy game.
Junior year it was a
bag with 32 pieces in it,
which were the first round
game and you get both teams,
10 bucks to enter and
the winner got 200 bucks
and I got $120.
Senior year I upped
it up and I made one team
on the cards, 64, and the
winner got $400 and I got $240.
(DRock laughs)
So, freshman year
I shocked the
school with my prediction,
sophomore year I can't
remember anything,
junior year I ran the pool,
senior year I ran the pool.
Yeah, the tournament's
always been big.
- [DRock] So that's
a staple in your life?
- The first Thursday
was actually one of the only
weird days I would
actually take off.
If I was talking
about missing no days,
I would leave at noon
and watch the first games.
I haven't done that in about
seven or eight years, though.
It's gotten crazy
but I used to do that.
- Hey, is it okay
if I Snapchat with you?
- Of course.
- I'm coming to
your thing tomorrow.
- How are you?
- Doing well.
How are you?
- Good. Oh!
Awesome.
- Awesome.
- [Gary] A real pleasure.
- I can't wait
to see you tomorrow.
- [Gary] Thank you,
talk to you soon.
(laughs)
- This is your sign,
but we're like...
- [Gary] That's a big ass
sign. What's up, buddy?
(whoops)
Good to see ya.
- You ready to party?
- I'm ready.
- Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure, man.
How are you?
- Good.
- [Gary] Good, man.
- [Shonduras] This is
the DRock, DRock's the man.
- [DRock] Good to meet you.
- [Shonduras]
Figure out our situation,
change all our flights, came
back, dude, just hustlin'
We went to, like,
four different skate parks
in a giant Greyhound
bus with my whole
space station crew, got
home, dropped everyone off,
immediately got in my car and
then came and picked you up.
That's why I'm
running a bit late.
- [Gary] I love it, man.
- This is us right here.
- Find some room.
Package acquired.
- DRock, GaryVee.
- [Gary] Here, present.
- Gary, you realize
that we're not going
to Hustle &amp; Grind right now,
we're going to a
Giant Wave to Surf.
- That's what I heard.
You guys know that I've never
surfed in my entire life?
- [Shonduras] That's why
we're doing it, dude.
- Like anything even remotely--
- [Tanner] And it's so much
different than real surfing.
- [Shonduras] Any time
I've ever hung out with you,
you were just
like, getting work done,
we're having good conversations,
like, I want none of that.
I just want to see you surfing.
- I want to see myself surfing,
like, I've never
done anything of balance,
like, no skate boarding,
no surfing.
- [Shonduras] This is
gonna be great.
- This is gonna be
really interesting.
- [Shonduras] So I
was like, I need some really
good clickbait
with GaryVee I bet if
I put him on a surf board
I'd be like
"Gary breaks his leg"
or something, like, viral video.
- I'm really hoping.
- Yeah, that's
what I'm going for.
- I'm looking for content.
- That's business right there.
- Content.
- His name is also
Sean, so it gets weird,
so we just call him Holiday.
- [Gary] Got it.
- I met him in
Honduras, so technically,
Shonduras as well.
- [Gary] Wow.
- I know, right?
- [Holiday] Like, I didn't know...
- [Gary] You guys
made up Holiday? Or...
- No, that's his last name,
- Last name.
- Yeah, it's his last name.
Then he's like my Alex, dude.
Like, my life would
not exist without him,
he's got me like, when
we got snowed in and stuff,
he's like "You're going here!
Now you're going in here!"
- [Gary] I remember.
- We had to jump out of
our Uber on the freeway,
change Ubers, go to
a different airport.
- [Tanner] Like,
straight up an island
in the middle of the freeway.
- [Shonduras] Like,
New York City was nuts.
- I love it.
- Yeah, it was, dude, the past
two days have been insane.
My buddies What's Inside
they live in Utah,
we're all hanging out.
It's gonna be
like, ultimate party.
- [Gary] And Tanner,
what about you, man,
like, what was your story?
I know you crush YouTube,
but like, how did it start?
- Originally, I was a
professional scooter rider,
so I like, went to
the skate park every day
for the last five years.
Just doing that, and I traveled,
like, all around for contests,
and then from there--
- Scooter, you said?
- Yeah.
- What does that mean?
I want to make sure.
- Like, a Razor scooter.
- Like Razor scooters.
- Yeah, but like, more pro.
- Yeah, okay, got it,
yeah, I've seen that.
- It's the same thing as BMX.
Yeah, so I did that.
- That's cool.
- Yeah, I did that for
five years, and then--
- How old are you now?
- 17. From there, I started
vlogging, and then--
- When was that?
- I just started for fun,
but that was a
year and a half ago.
- Go ahead.
- So I had a little bit
of a following from scootering.
- Yep.
- And then I just
kept vlogging for fun
and then I had a video
that went kind of viral.
- Yep.
- So then I got a bunch
of subscribers really fast
and then from there--
- What was the video about?
- Hoverboards.
So then from there, I like,
I made it more about me,
and then I slowly transitioned
away from scootering
and then more just about me
so that I could like,
keep the same fan base.
- Yep.
- And then just grew
it and kept doing it,
and now I've been doing it
daily for the past eight months.
But before that,
I did every other day.
- Understood.
- Real talk about
this, though, like,
I mean, skateboarding's
rough, cement, all that stuff.
Like, this is fun,
like you can do it,
it doesn't hurt to
fall or anything like that,
the body surfing's super fun.
- [Gary] I like pain.
(laughing)
I like losing, man.
Like, I like that shit.
Meaning, I don't
like all that stuff
because I don't have time.
Like, the same
reason I don't golf,
I just don't
have time for anything
because I just love what I do,
but, like, as
soon as we get there,
I'm going to be focused as fuck.
(group laughter)
I'm not gonna be
like, "Oh, this is lame."
You know what I mean?
DRock, you need Wifi
to post today's episode?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Shonduras] We got good
Wifi at the space station.
Space Wifi.
- But we're first going
to that other place, right?
Does that place have Wifi?
- [DRock] I can upload them--
- 'Cause what, it's already 11?
- [DRock] I'll do
it on my phone.
- What time is it?
- [Tanner] It'll be 11, yeah.
- [Shonduras] Oh.
- Somebody from the company
just asked me why the draft,
why the March Madness
thing is mandatory.
I said it'll be in
tomorrow's DailyVee.
DRock just asked
me the same question.
I make the whole
company fill out a bracket
for the tournament.
- What's the March,
so I got a couple
tweets, like Casey Neistat,
GaryVee, March Madness,
is there an actual thing
with influencers, or like
that's just
something in the company?
- Maybe there's
something, but for me,
I'm not in any of that.
It's a VaynerMedia
thing, that's been like,
like the winner,
like I sent to Australia,
like, I make it a whole...
- [Shonduras] Just have fun.
- Yeah.
- [Shonduras] Yeah.
- It's a big deal.
I like that I'm
tagging Layton, Utah,
this is when you get
people like "What the fuck!"
- [Shonduras] Yeah, exactly.
- They're in Layton, Utah.
What's that, brother?
- Are you into cars?
- No.
- No?
- Nah, I'm super like,
not cool that way, like--
- [Shonduras] No, me too, man.
It's so hard 'cause
all these people talk cars.
- You love cars?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I don't give a
fuck about cars at all.
- [Shonduras] I know,
like, good cars have NOS.
- He goes, "You like cars?
"Yeah, I don't give
a fuck about cars."
- [Shonduras] That's like,
my attitude exactly,
except for I edit it.
- Like, people are like "Yo!"
- [Shonduras] I don't
give a rat's about cars.
- "This fucking car can
do this," I'm like, yeah.
Like, yeah, but I get it.
Like, that's the
best part of the world.
But I love people
that are into shit.
Like I love when
my friends are like
"Look under the hood,"
or know how fast it is
or give a fuck
about tires and shit.
(group laughter)
I think that's awesome,
because I get it, like,
I'm into like, I'm
into, fucking, like,
going to garage sales
and like, finding like,
toys from the '80s and being like
"Yo I bought this for 50 cents
and I sold it for six bucks"
and that fucking gives me
the greatest,
like, fucking rush ever.
It's 7:57.
- [Shonduras] 7:57,
we've got 30 minutes.
This is the best place
to eat in the entire world.
- [Gary] So let's eat it.
- [DRock] Right now?
- I'll do it here.
- [Shonduras] Tanner
doing a back flip.
- Ready?
- [Shonduras] Yeah!
- [DRock] Yes!
- [Gary] Jesus!
How does that feel?
Okay?
How about there?
- More!
- That hurts, right?
- Yeah.
- Dude.
- Dude, Gary could drop you!
- No, seriously,
it's crazy, right?
- The best part is I
had no idea about anything.
Today I was like,
"What am I doing?"
Literally, like
when I got off the plane.
Off the plane!
- When you were like
"I don't have a swim suit"
I was like "Wait, does
Gary know what we're doing?"
- 45 minutes ago I was
like "What am I doing?"
What are you gonna do?
- Try a front flip.
- I don't know
how to front flip.
- I can teach you.
- I'm gonna
break my fucking neck.
- Don't jump too high
because you don't
know how to do it yet.
But you just kind of jump.
- This is like, the
end of me, right now.
- Tuck your head in.
- Go ahead, alright, go ahead.
- That's you, dog!
- I want to see you do it.
Let me just, I...
One more time, you
and then I'm ready to go.
(cheering)
- Holy shit!
- [Shonduras] One with no hands!
You got this, one more no hands.
- I don't, that's
literally the first time
I've ever did that in my life.
- Gary's getting
extreme in here.
- Ever. Ever in my life.
I don't even know what happened.
- Good hands, a little better,
go a little bit under the back.
(cheering)
- Holy shit!
Oh my god.
- Gary just goes off in Utah!
- I'm pumped. That was good?
- [Shonduras] Alright,
let's go indoor surf.
- Is that good?
- [DRock] Great.
- That was the most extreme
thing I've ever done in my life.
Not our normal thing, DRock.
(cheering)
("Waves" by Shallou)
- [DRock] You're welcome.
- GaryVee versus wave.
- [Gary] I've now learned that
the front foot is the back foot
and the back
foot is the front foot
and I'm making slight progress.
Love that footage.
- [David] That looks great.
(cheering)
- Oh my God! What is life!
- Guys, I'm an
extreme sports superstar.
- Yes.
(laughing)
- Learning to
fall's super important.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Yeah, I mean I should...
(laughs)
You guys should
have told me that before.
The first, literally
the first fucking time
my elbow exploded
all over my fucking body.
I feel like I'm a
cross between Kelly Slater
and Tony Hawk at this point.
- [Shonduras] Alright,
this is the part
where we take you
guys to the space station.
You ready for some
space station, Gary?
- He gets to ride the drift car.
- The drift cars. Professional
fun-haver training camp.
- [Gary] I think my stomach's
more like Vin Diesel.
(group laughter)
God, yeah, you know what?
I'm really in the mood now.
I'm trying to, like,
will it into the universe.
I'm, like, trying to
will my vibes right now
towards two kids in
Kansas to invent some sort
of crazy-ass...
I hope they call it Shmuga.
Since that's what
I always say. Yeah.
Follow me on Shmuga!
- What do you do on the Shmuga
(Gary laughs)
- I'm a huge shmuger.
(group laughter)
- I used to run my
business out of my basement.
I upgraded to here,
brought the basement with me,
brought
everything from the basement,
brought it here, made it better.
This is just, like,
random property to play with.
Green screen.
We' re really into VR,
mixed reality, right now.
- Yep.
- So, playing a video game,
we film it, layer in the game
so it looks like
you're inside the video game.
Gaming, the VR
computer, this is Brandon.
(high-five)
Brandon works on brand
deals, special projects,
- [Gary] A pleasure.
- VR stuff.
This is where Holiday sits.
Holiday runs my entire
life, he's my schedule,
call, calendars, everything.
This is Pookie, he runs
my second You Tube channel.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- Sorry, everybody's
got their own, weird name.
Like this is Pookie,
that's what his mom
used to call him
so I just adopted it.
He runs the second
channel with challenger stuff.
This is me, this is Tall
Chicken, he's been with me
since the very beginning,
editing the best day ever vlogs.
- [Gary] I love it.
- That's the team.
Mail room, check it out.
Outgoing, dude, we write
back almost every single fan.
Look at that,
that's outgoing, dawg.
- I'm proud of ya on that..
- There it is.
Charging table, cereal wall.
In case you didn't know
I really, really like cereal.
And then fans send us cereal
so these are all from fans.
They write on them,
they draw their own cereals.
- How do I go backwards?
- This is not like a real
car where you're yanking it
and turning it.
That's, like, backwards.
It's just little
turns like this, okay?
- [Gary] Little turns.
- So turn it this
way, there's your gas.
- Alright.
- [Shonduras] I'm
gonna get ya set up.
(engine starts)
- Holy shit.
It's got juice.
- Okay, see where you are?
It's not there, it's right here.
Kinda just go into
the corner real quick
till you get used to it.
- Alright.
Oh, shit!
(laughing)
Holy...
- [Shonduras] Little turns!
- [Gary] Little turns.
Little turns.
Holy shit.
("Rock" by Brainpower)
- Little turns.
Little turn.
Little turns.
(laughs and exclaims)
Jesus!
Little turns, little turns.
Like driving stick.
DRock! DRock!
DRock died, guys.
DRock, you okay?
DRock wasn't even on it.
(all laugh and exclaim)
- [Gary] Little turns!
(crashes)
Oh god.
(laughs)
- Sorry, DRock.
Little turns!
- [Holiday] Woah!
- [Gary] Jesus.
- Alright, I lost a
little control there.
Gonna feel this!
(crashes)
Woah!
(exclaiming)
(tires screech)
- Oh!
That was pretty good.
(tires screech)
(exclaiming)
Oh, I got it! I got it!
(crashes)
(laughing)
- [Shonduras] Gary,
Gary, this is what happens
when you ride the
go carts too much.
(laughs)
- D Rock!
I just heard DRock.
- [Shonduras] Where
is this DRock guy at?
Nice drift cart test. Good job.
- I love it.
- [Tanner] You get,
like, a medium pass.
(crashes)
- Oh!
- Yes! That's
Gary's mark! (clapping)
Yes, Gary left
his mark right here.
(laughing)
- [Tanner] Now just
go backwards and pull it.
- That was pretty good.
- [Tanner] Did
you get it, DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah, I got it.
- DRock, that was a solid shot.
- I need you to sign
that mark right there.
- [Tanner] There
it is, right there.
- Bam.
- [DRock] That's
GaryVee's mark.
- [Tanner] Not bad, huh?
- [Shonduras] Forever.
- [Tanner] Not
bad at all. (laughing)
(laughing)
- [Gary] DRock, can
you upload the episode?
Hey, man, how
are ya? (boy giggles)
- Good, man, I'm Dan.
- Dan, such a
pleasure. How are you?
- Doin' great.
- I love how I'm
wearing the Macho Man shirt.
- [Dan] Dude, Macho Man. Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah,
fast forward a little.
Yep, this is it. He did it.
I'm the best at this.
See, you go like this.
- Like you're flipping them?
- Yeah.
- And you try to take
the other person's pencil?
- Yeah. Like, you
go: (pencil snaps)
- Alright.
- Oh my god!
- [Shonduras] Brandon's
got the goods.
- My god.
- [Brandon] Okay, Gary.
- [DRock] Hold on,
what are we doing?
- Pencil fighting.
- I have no idea what this is.
I didn't do this,
Gary's teaching here.
- [Gary] Lower.
- [Shonduras] Lower.
Oh, I see you're
going for that metal too.
Oh, that hurt me. That hurt me.
Oh, wait, I
can't move it. (sighs)
Ooh. What about the firmness?
Like, do you
have to hold it firm?
- Yep.
(all laugh)
- [Shonduras] Oh, pencil lost.
- [Gary] He was
broken on the inside.
(exclaiming)
I lost my eraser.
When you lose your eraser
that's when you're in trouble.
- [DRock] Once that
inside's broken you're done for.
- [Tanner] How are
you doing that?
(pencil snaps)
- You're in trouble,
I cracked you. Yep.
(laughing and exclaiming)
- [Shonduras] Nobody
has it, nobody has it.
- Let me have it. Oh,
how did that stay alive?
(laughing)
- There's the lead!
- Alright, who's next?
- [DRock] Why you
scaring the kid, Gary?
- I will destroy
this kid. (gasps)
- [Shonduras] This is next
level strategy here.
- Oh, I am
worried it's gonna break.
Like, I keep feeling it
more and more.
- [Shonduras] Where
did it come from?
Like, how old were you
when you were doing this?
- Mid '80's. Like, this
was the mid '80's big thing.
Ready?
- [Tall Chicken] Let's go.
- [Shonduras] Wait,
we're just warming up?
- [Gary] Oh my god!
That was a huge shot.
I'm in trouble.
I lost my eraser I should
be finished by now.
Ow!
(laughs)
(exclaiming)
Oh, I'm in trouble.
I feel the internal bleeding.
(laughing)
- You better be ready
for a victory lap, DRock.
- Ooh, I don't know about this.
(sighs)
(pencil snaps)
Oh!
- This is where boys
become men right here.
(pencil breaks)
(exclaiming)
- What you gonna do?
Bret "The Hitman" Hart
is considered
the excellence of execution.
He's one of the all
time great wrestlers.
He comes from a big
time wrestling family.
I was an '80's baby.
In the '80's he was
part of a tag team called,
The Hart Foundation,
with Jim "The Anvil" Neidhart.
And then he eventually
became a solo wrestler.
- [Shonduras] Right now.
Who is this guy?
- [Gary] And became a
big time solo wrestler
and when he left
WWF to go to WCW,
he was supposed to
gracefully kind of leave,
but Vince McMahon screwed him
- [Shonduras] Duh.
- And he made Shawn Michaels
beat him--
- I remember Vince McMahon.
and it made it seem
like Shawn Michaels,
the way it was choreographed,
Bret the Hitman Hart was
supposed to kick out
of the move,
which was the Sharpshooter,
which was his own move,
Shawn Michaels had him in it,
but McMahon made the
ref call it making it seem
like Bret submitted
to his own move.
Bret like spit on him,
it was a whole to do.
- [Shonduras] Wow.
- But he's one of the
great wrestlers of all time.
And it's really awesome
that he's on this signature.
I'm pretty hard core about saying
that nobody is
really my business idol,
but when I'm forced into it,
I do say that Vince McMahon
and Walt Disney are two
people I think a lot about
because they're storytellers.
I mean I you really think
about what's happening here,
the cereal like
if you even look at,
even the new age
stars of social media,
actually are much more grounded
in the old storytelling of like
you're creating pillars,
pencil fighting,
cereal,
you're just
creating these genres
these worlds you live in.
What Vince did extremely well,
WWF as I call it,
now WWE.
Is he owned the naming rights
to all these characters.
He invented these characters.
Him and his inner crew.
They invented,
you know, Mr. Perfect.
They invented Demolition,
they invented The Undertaker.
And then they owned the IP,
so there's a human being who's
Brutus the Barber
Beefcake or Hillbilly Jim
or Junkyard Dog or Iron Sheik.
But they don't
own the IP, he does.
And that IP goes on to
be worth a lot of money,
and so, he's an
extremely strong storyteller.
And what he did,
which I loved,
was he took a regional business,
wrestling in the early '80's
going all the way
back to the '40's and '50's,
was regional.
So there was like,
the northeast league,
and the south league,
and wrestlers
like Andre the Giant
would go and travel
in different places.
What he did was turned
WWF into a national player
by being smart
and understanding cable
television distribution,
Saturday morning distribution,
MTV distribution,
and Saturday Night Live,
there used to
be something called
Saturday Night's Main Event,
which would run
once every eight weeks
instead of SNL.
And he just built a whole world.
Wrestlemania,
his invention really,
besides boxing,
created the
Pay-Per-View industry.
He's a real pioneer.
- [Shonduras] I thought it
was just a bunch of dudes
going hard in the ring.
I had no idea.
- You know what's so funny?
So much of what we do today
even when you're
like, "Hey Snapchat crew,
"I'm about to unveil
my video on YouTube."
I just watched
some of your content.
- Yeah.
- Well that's what
Vince literally invented
before big wrestlers
that he would sign
would come to the WWF.
He would do these
little monologues like
Razor Ramon's like
"I'm coming for you Macho Man."
And for like
weeks every Saturday,
you're like, "Wait a
minute this guys coming!"
And then by the
time he finally shows up,
in like week nine,
you already thought
he was the coolest.
So he would play that
build up better than anybody.
And now you see a lot of those
behaviors in social media.
Which is like, "Tomorrow I'm
going to drop this thing,"
or every 10th of
the month one of your
pieces of clothes, right?
One of the greatest
matches of all time.
If you Google it right now,
every top 10 list is
Macho Man Randy Savage
versus Ricky The
Dragon Steamboat,
Intercontinental Championship,
Wrestlemania 3 I think?
- It was definitely three.
- And it was like a 40
minute match because they were
both so great at improv,
like they just had a cadence
with each other.
It's kind of like
a dancing partner.
- [Shonduras] They went
for 40 minutes just?
- I like boxing a lot as well,
and there's this
saying in boxing, like,
styles make fights, right?
So like you can
have two great fighters,
best in the world, and
all of us would fall asleep
by the eighth round,
and you could have two guys
that are okay but
they just matched.
Macho Man and Ricky The Dragon
Steamboat, their styles,
just, there was something,
I mean, look at this,
this is real, you see it?
- [Man] Oh my gosh!
- Like literally, just
talking about it gives me,
look at this, like literally.
Like literally
goosebumps, literally.
- [Shonduras] He's got
real goosebumps. (laughs)
- I'm telling you
like I'm sure you're like,
it's almost worth
signing up for WWE Channel
just to have access
to watch that match,
it's that all-time.
- All right we have the
power team assembled here,
with the wrestling belt.
This is Bret The
Hitman Hart, The Undertaker,
and Howard Finkle, he's the
longest tenured employee of WWE.
- This is what we do.
- That's so funny.
We cut stuff open.
- That's amazing.
- Okay guys.
(saw whirring)
Hold her tight!
Oh!
- Completely normal!
(cheering)
- Oh!
- Yeah!
- Smells awesome.
(laughing) Smells
like that big dude's hair.
- [Shonduras] That's
just creepy.
- Smells good too.
Did you smell it?
Dude smell it.
- [Man] Like it smells good.
(laughing)
- I can never cut this hair.
- It's really good hair,
if I had that
hair I'd be dominating.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I got your
half, there you go.
- Oh you do,
thank you very much.
- Lincoln, your half.
Successful cut!
- Yes!
- [Shonduras] Don't remove
the gold, I want it forever.
- Seeing the inside
of a wrestling belt,
was that fun, Lincoln?
- What you gonna do when Lincoln
comes to run wild on you?
(laughing)
- [Shonduras] Are you sure you
don't wanna go there's like
skydiving, like
anything, you good?
- Finished.
- You done?
- No VR rollercoaster?
- This is the creepy room.
- This is super creepy.
- Don't worry about it.
- Hello? (laughing)
- Cool, cool.
- Awesome.
- Thanks.
- Such a pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- Let me get one,
right here, hometown.
- Gary, space station,
how was it?
- The best.
- The best,
check out my boy Gary.
- I love you guys.
- Instagram, YouTube,
everything, the best.
- Best.
- Oh my gosh it
worked, we got it.
- Amazing hospitality
from this man.
- Space station high five guys.
- High five guys.
- Nice meeting you.
- Dude, yeah.
Anything I can help, reach out.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
- Seriously.
- You too.
If you ever want, need
help growing your whatever.
(laughing)
- come on!
- Sorry, sorry!
I didn't know that was his.
- Later man.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- [Shonduras] Call me.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- Thank you, take care.
- [Shonduras] This is the end.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- Can I hug you?
- [Gary] Of course, brother.
- Good, I appreciate it.
- Of course.
- We appreciate it.
- Hi!
- How's it going?
- How are you?
- Good, good, good.
- Such a pleasure,
what's your name?
- I'm Christina.
- Christina, such a pleasure.
- We live in Salt Lake City,
so we decided that we
would drive 35 minute
for like the 17% chance
of possibly meeting you.
- Yeah, it was super
saw it on like 17--
- It was super weird
'cause we were like hiding
over there in the woods.
- [Gary] Are you kidding?
Not at all don't
worry, such a pleasure.
- I wanna give you a hug.
- [Gary] Please.
Thank you so much.
- [Man] This is ultimate combo.
We gotta get down there.
- That's good.
- That's awesome.
- Can you do the whole
like, you're gonna die thing?
- Heck yeah, this is for you.
- Wait, what?
I don't even know
what this thing is.
You're gonna die thing?
- Somebody asked me like,
somebody asked me like, hello.
- Hey, he's gonna die, one sec.
- Driving 35 minutes is
like what you do, right?
It's like you get one
shot, this could deal--
- [Christina] Just wanna say
we appreciate you for sure.
- Very sweet.
Yeah I mean listen, I don't
know how to play this game
without recognizing
that we get one shot,
you get these one experiences,
this is like the one time
all of us, this dude,
what's your name?
- Alex, nice to meet you.
- Alex, really nice to meet you.
This is it, this
like the, this is 100%,
I'm gonna say,
looking at the mix of people,
our one time being all together.
- [Shonduras] We nailed it!
- We crushed it!
Wrapping up a long day.
Defininitely a
different kind of DailyVee.
("Understand" by
Bazanji Ft. Eve Devonport)